Traductor: Jennifer Lemck
Revisor: Rodrigo Sena
Quería compartir con vosotros que
hoy es el primer día que salgo a la calle,
Llevo 10 semanas
tumbada boca abajo.
El primer mes,
el más difícil de todos,
lo he pasado con 130 grapas
y 50 puntos en toda esta zona.
Han sido 10 semanas
sin poder moverme mucho,
sin poder sentarme,
sin poder tumbarme boca arriba,
sin poder mirar un techo,
por no decir un cielo.
Os quiero contar un poquito mi historia.
Me caigo con 11 años, mientras
estaba veraneando con mis padres,
y me rompo el coxis.
Y este culetazo cambia
mi vida por completo.
Desde entonces,
sufro un dolor crónico muy severo
que consiste en una alteración
del sistema somatosensorial del cuerpo.
Entonces, yo siento esta zona
de mi espalda como un volcán.
Tengo un montón de cicatrices que queman.
En toda la zona, he perdido
la sensibilidad, pero, en cambio,
tengo muchísimo miedo
a que me rocen.
He pasado muchísimas veces
por el quirófano.
La última, esta que os estoy contando.
Esta operación se ha hecho con el fin
de almohadillar la zona de mi sacro
y que pueda hacer cosas tan sencillas
como sentarme o tumbarme boca arriba,
porque hasta ahora mismo,
no es posible.
Es agotador emocionalmente,
es muy agotador vivir con lo que la
Sociedad Española de Neurología
llama "el peor de los dolores".
¿Y por qué es el peor de los dolores?
Porque, por un lado,
tiene muy mal tratamiento farmacológico,
es muy difícil de tratar,
y por otro lado, es el peor de los dolores
porque la forma en la que lo vivimos
las personas que lo sentimos,
es muy, muy intensa.
Yo sé que muchos de vosotros
podréis decir "no se te nota nada",
"no parece que esté enferma",
o "qué buen aspecto tienes".
Incluso "qué pena, una mujer tan joven".
Entiendo que a primera vista,
el dolor no se nota,
pero cuando observamos los ojos
de las personas que sentimos dolor,
de verdad que sí, podéis ver
el sufrimiento en nuestros ojos.
Yo crecí, me desarrollé,
llena de dolores,
llena de visitas al médico,
llena de rehabilitaciones,
llena de esperanza,
de frustración, de negativas,
desde los 11 años hasta ahora, imaginad.
Hasta que dos de las opciones
terapéuticas que me dieron,
fueron terribles para mí.
Por un lado, el cóctel de fármacos
que me llevaron a pasar
por una adicción muy fuerte,
y acabar en el centro
de ayuda a la drogadicción,
para poder retirar esos fármacos
que los médicos me habían mandado.
Y por otro lado,
los dos neuroestimuladores
que colocan en mi espalda
para engañar a mi cerebro
y que crea que siente menos dolor.
Todo esto no funciona.
De hecho, desde que quitan
los neuroestimuladores
no puedo volver a ponerme
un pantalón en mi vida.
Pero, claro, no se nota nada.
Cuando personas como yo
vamos al aeropuerto
y pedimos la asistencia
a personas con movilidad reducida,
muchas veces no nos creen.
Muchas veces notas
la mirada de esa persona
que quiere que le demuestres que
realmente tienes una movilidad reducida.
Y aunque no lo hacen aposta,
aunque ese microgesto es muy leve,
para nosotros es un dolor añadido.
El 17 % de la población española
sufre dolor crónico.
Y sólo en niños, un 37 % de menores
entre 8 y 16 años sufre de dolor.
Por lo tanto es un tema que nos afecta
a muchísimos y muchísimas de nosotros.
Al fin y al cabo, somos
un conjunto de personas
que estamos sufriendo en silencio
porque el dolor no se puede demostrar,
que estamos muy incomprendidas
y a las que el Sistema Nacional de Salud
no da ningún tipo de solución
o de abordaje multidisciplinario,
aparte del tratamiento farmacológico
o los quirófanos.
Porque el dolor es muy difícil de medir,
¿cómo mides tu dolor?
Hay una escala del 1 al 10,
lo que se llama el EVA,
en la que el 1 es
el menor dolor posible
y el 10, el máximo dolor
que una persona puede tolerar.
Si tú me preguntas ahora mismo:
"¿qué dolor tienes, Carola?".
Con este cambio de tiempo,
ahora mismo estoy por encima de un 9,
teniendo en cuenta que el 10
es el máximo dolor soportable.
Pero claro, ¿mi 8 es diferente de tu 8?
¿A tí te duele más que a mí?
En realidad, ¿qué más da?
Al final el dolor es algo subjetivo.
Tened en cuenta que
las personas que sufrimos dolor
muchos días podemos
perder el conocimiento
cuando tenemos un brote
o un pico de dolor.
Hay días que puede ser
varias veces al día
y hay otros días
que no es ninguna,
porque el dolor no siempre
se comporta igual.
¿De qué depende el dolor?
Pues, el dolor depende de mil factores.
En primer lugar, las emociones.
Yo creo que las emociones
están muy ligadas al dolor.
Una emoción positiva, como estar
aquí con vosotros ahora,
reduce el dolor.
Las emociones negativas,
el cambio de temperatura,
el estrés, la calidad del sueño,
si has discutido con alguien...
Cualquier mínima cosa te altera
y hace que el dolor se dispare.
En algunos momentos,
como os digo, no siento dolor.
Cuando duermo, cuando medito, por ejemplo,
o cuando estoy concentrada en algo.
Entonces, cuando tú ves
que no sientes dolor
es una sensación muy difícil de explicar
porque por un lado estás muy contenta
porque no tienes dolor,
pero por otro lado piensas:
si la lesión es la misma,
¿cómo es posible que
este ratito no tenga dolor?
A mí el tiempo me ha enseñado
que lo mejor es no hacerle demasiado caso.
No prestarle atención,
mirarle de reojo,
porque si le mentas,
vuelve a aparecer.
La calidad de vida de una persona como yo
es agotadora.
Y lo peor es que al final,
la calidad de vida con el tiempo,
se va mermando poco a poco
y te va deteriorando muchísimo.
Solo el hecho de levantarte,
de ducharte, de comer algo,
de vestirte, ya es una lucha titánica,
por no decir salir a trabajar
o tener un poquito de vida social.
A mí me recuerda muchísimo
la vida que llevamos
a cuando juego con mis sobrinas
al juego de la oca
y de repente caes en la casilla del pozo.
Entonces, ves como todos los demás
siguen avanzando en sus vidas,
y tú estás todo el rato
volviendo a la casilla de salida,
hay que volver a operar,
o este medicamento no ha funcionado,
o lo que esperábamos
que fuera, ahora no es.
Todo esto al final
te hace levantarte cada día
como si hubieras caído en ese pozo
y volvemos a la casilla de salida.
Incluso algunos días tengo la sensación
de que nos han castigado
con tres turnos sin tirar.
Mientras mi vida se iba desarrollando
desde niña con todas estas operaciones,
con estos fármacos, con estas drogas,
mi vida, mi pasión,
lo que me ayudaba a seguir viva,
era la música.
A los 15 años empiezo
a hacer mi programa de rock
en una radio local de Madrid.
Y con 18, mientras hacía la carrera,
trabajaba en el mundo de la música
como jefa de prensa,
como tour manager
como promotora de conciertos
o como coordinadora de festivales.
Lógicamente, este ritmo de vida
era frenético.
Para una espalda como la mía,
no le venía muy bien,
tened en cuenta que la vida
de una persona con dolor
ya es suficientemente difícil,
como para que el trabajo
sea una carga más.
En mi caso, gracias a dios,
ha sido siempre una bendición.
Pero después de la 11ª operación,
los médicos dicen que se acabó,
que no puedo continuar trabajando,
que no puedo seguir yendo de gira.
Y confieso que esa noticia
casi me duele más que el propio culetazo,
porque de repente tu vida se corta,
de repente tienes que volver
a reinsertarte en la vida laboral.
Tú piensas: ¿Cómo voy a vivir
con tanto dolor,
después de tantas operaciones,
con la calidad de vida tan mermada?
¿Cómo voy a encontrar ese hilo
que me mantenía la vida
que entonces era la música?
Llegué a pensar que, por un momento,
no tenía nada donde agarrarme.
En ese momento de crisis,
porque es una crisis bastante fuerte,
por un lado dices: "bueno,
voy a asimilar y voy a rendirme al dolor".
Y cuando hablo de rendirme al dolor,
hablo de no intentar
todo el rato buscarle salida,
volverme loca intentando
entender qué ocurría,
sino que lo mejor era decir:
"Vale. Tengo dolor, voy a vivir con dolor,
y la vida a partir de ahora va a ser así".
Por otro lado, el yoga,
las meditaciones en silencio,
los retiros con el Lama,
me sirven de muchísimo.
Pero lo mejor vino gracias a
una planta llamada cannabis.
Sé que muchos de vosotros pensaréis:
"el cannabis -o cáñamo o marihuana-
es ilegal, es una droga,
hay abuso, coloca".
Bueno, pues yo os puedo decir
que para mí, es terapia.
A mí, me ha salvado la vida.
Y desde entonces,
ese hilo que no encontraba
cuando he dejado la música,
ese hilo ha sido esta planta.
Desde entonces dedico mi vida
a investigar y a defenderlo.
Tened en cuenta que (sobre ello)
hay más de 20.000 estudios científicos
ya publicados en el mundo.
Dicen las autoridades sanitarias
que no hay suficiente
evidencia científica.
Para que os hagáis una idea,
son los mismos estudios
que han hecho falta con el paracetamol,
el omeprazol o el Valium.
Pero no hay suficiente
evidencia científica.
Yo entiendo que el cannabis
es complejo a nivel bioquímico,
entiendo que es una planta poco habitual,
que sus componentes cambian mucho
de una variedad a otra,
y que del mismo modo
que cambian los componentes,
cambian sus efectos.
Por lo tanto, es muy difícil
meterlo en una única caja.
Pero este camino hasta que entiendes bien
cómo funciona la planta,
de prueba y error, te toca hacerlo sola.
Te toca hacerlo sin médicos
y sin profesionales de la salud
que te puedan apoyar.
Entonces comienzas a buscarte la vida
para conseguir tu medicina.
Primero con un amigo,
luego con un camello,
luego vas a un club social de cannabis
y acabas cultivándote tus propias plantas.
En mi casa, por ejemplo,
tengo 16 genéticas distintas.
Pero si os paráis a pensar,
imaginad que tenéis que ir
a Las Barranquillas a comprar
vuestra medicación a diario.
¿A que suena un poquito absurdo?
Todo este período de 5 años,
en los que la planta entró en mi vida,
comienzo a hacerme con ella,
a entender los componentes,
a entender las diferentes genéticas,
ha servido no solo para que
mi calidad de vida mejore,
sino para poder ayudar a los demás
y compartir todo aquello que yo aprendí
a base de prueba y error.
Por esto fundo Dosemociones,
que es una asociación
que asesora y atiende
a todas estas personas
que estamos sufriendo,
que queremos probar el cannabis medicinal
porque sabemos que funciona
en algunos casos.
No es que sea una panacea,
pero funciona.
Y estamos hablando de
un montón de patologías.
Estamos hablando de cáncer,
de Crohn, de colitis ulcerosas,
de epilepsia, de fibromialgia,
de artritis y artrosis, de las migrañas,
estamos hablando de Parkinson,
de Alzheimer, de epilepsia refractaria.
Estamos hablando
de un montón de patologías.
Además, en la asociación
no solo asesoramos a las personas
y les enseñamos los
distintos cannabinoides,
las vías de administración,
las diferentes genéticas,
todo siempre bajo el mando de un médico,
sino que además les enseñamos
a cultivar su propia medicina.
Y no solo les enseñamos
a cultivar su propia medicina,
sino que además, posteriormente,
se las analizamos en laboratorios
para saber qué porcentaje
de cannabinoides tiene cada planta
y para saber que está en
buenas condiciones de salubridad.
Para que os hagáis una idea,
el año pasado atendimos
293 personas solo nosotras,
somos 4 mujeres.
De las cuales, 14 eran niños
y 203 eran mujeres,
del total de 293 personas.
Yo soy consciente de que
hablaros de esta terapia en niños
puede chocaros muchísimo.
Y estamos muy cansados de oir el
chiste de "¿le dais porros a los niños?".
En ningún caso le damos
porros a los niños.
Tened en cuenta, por otro lado,
que en los niños los efectos
placebo y nocebo apenas existen.
Por lo cual, los estudios
están corroborando
lo que nosotras ya llevamos
3 o 4 años sabiendo
a través de la experiencia
y del conocimiento.
Por ejemplo, el caso de los niños
con epilepsia refractaria.
Normalmente, estamos viendo
que entre un 40 % y 80 % de los casos
no solo mejora su calidad de vida,
sino que las crisis se reducen
de unas 30 crisis al día,
por ejemplo, a 3 crisis al día.
Para un niño que está
convulsionando día y noche,
para unos padres
que están sufriendo,
ese alivio es una maravilla.
Ningún medicamento hasta ahora
lo había conseguido.
Esto gracias a una sola molécula
que se llama CBD.
Pero en conjunto la molécula
más potente que tenemos
a nivel terapéutico es el THC,
que es la que coloca.
Esta molécula es la culpable,
por ende, de la mala fama
y de la resistencia a administrarlo
por parte de las autoridades sanitarias
aunque ya hay conocimiento suficiente
para ofrecer al paciente
regímenes de administración
para que se reduzca la psicoactividad
o el colocón del THC
y el paciente esté cómodo.
¿Cómo explicar cómo alivia el THC?
¿Cómo alivia el cannabis?
El alivio es brutal.
Es un alivio por un lado, físico,
por otro lado hay un alivio emocional,
por otro lado ayuda a descansar.
Por otro lado nos ayuda muchísimo
a mejorar el estado de ánimo
y es asombroso cuando funciona,
lo bien que funciona.
¿Qué hacemos ante esta situación?
No se debate, no se regula,
aquí nadie hace nada,
miles de personas lo estamos usando,
mamás con niños,
niños con mamás,
y adultos que estamos
en nuestro derecho de tener acceso
al mejor tratamiento posible
para nuestro dolor.
Porque el dolor
no puede esperar.
Esta es la razón por la que,
mientras todo esto ocurre,
nosotras nos organizamos, nos reunimos
y compartimos nuestro dolor.
Y no solo eso, ahora vamos a impulsar
un estudio con 200 pacientes
de cáncer y dolor
para poder medir
cómo mejora su calidad de vida.
Pero todo esto
lo estamos haciendo sin ayudas.
Sin ayudas gubernamentales,
sin ayudas privadas,
porque esto es una droga.
Imaginad cómo nos sentimos ante el rechazo
tanto de las autoridades sanitarias
como de los políticos.
Es una pena que el cannabis medicinal
no esté regulado.
Y es una pena
que sea el último recurso
porque pensad que 120.000 pacientes,
según el Observatorio Español
de Cannabis Medicinal,
estamos en el mercado negro.
Es muy injusto que estemos
en esta situación
tanto sanitaria como jurídica.
Quienes sufrimos dolor
lo vamos a hacer toda la vida
y creo que como sociedad merecemos
que se exploren todas las vías posibles.
Nadie merece el dolor,
pero el dolor sí que merece
atención, cuidado y cariño.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplauso)